I'm happy and in love so I've got no
need for rizz Tom Holland gives fans
rare insight into his relationship with
Zendaya saying he's happy and in love so
that's our big thing at the moment it
all went down in a new interview with
BuzzFeed when the actor was asked about
the secret to his writs rizz if you
don't know is short for Charisma
particularly while flirting yeah I do my
part where I can for sure that's when
Tom explains he has no Grizz whatsoever
adding you need to fall in love with him
for it to work long game probably making
a movie with each other it definitely
helps when the characters you're playing
are falling in love with one another you
can sort of blow the lines a little bit
sounds familiar right
I really like you
I really like you too
[Music]
Tom and Zendaya met on the set of
Spider-Man in 2017 where romance rumors
first sparked and it happens all the
time and of course you know we we
expected it I mean it's it's um it comes
with the territory it comes from the job
so it's all good Flash Forward to 2021
the duo went public with their love
after years of playing koi about their
relationship have you found that it's
hard to date in Hollywood so yeah it's
such a young age of course it is I mean
it's hard to stay at any age I mean it
doesn't matter you know where you are
either I mean it's just hard to date in
general long game probably making a
movie with each other it definitely
helps when the characters you're playing
are falling in love with one another you
can sort of blur the lines a little bit
yeah you heard that right happy and in
love people honestly this means the
world to me but then shouldn't get used
to Tom dishing on his love in a new
Interview With The Hollywood Reporter
Tom explains why the couple is so
private about their romance saying their
relationship is something they are
incredibly protective of and want to
keep as sacred as possible we don't
think that we owe it to anyone it's our
thing and it has nothing to do with our
careers
and speaking of careers Tom's crushing
it thank you very much E.T recently
chatted with the a-lister at the
premiere for his new Apple TV Plus show
the crowded room it never struck you as
strange that this man just showed up to
save you
figured I was lucky have you ever been
lucky
no not only does Tom star in the
psychological Thriller but he also
served as an executive producer so how
was
that Wednesday you know the the
producing sort of things was a really
steep learning curve yeah being on set
performing in this role going to those
Dark Places while also you know handling
certain issues that happen on every day
on a film set was a little bit
overwhelming
this wasn't a random shooting he's
hiding something
what happened in that house where did
they all go
we have these blank spots being a part
of the edit working with the producers
building the show casting everything I
loved it as for his future as Spider-Man
five years ago was your first one
homecoming
um fans cannot imagine anyone else
assuming the role how long do you think
you'll carry on the towards of
Spider-Man Betty I think as long as we
can do justice to Peter Parker as long
as we can keep elevating the IP and
making the films better and making them
mean more then I'll be there I'd be
stupid to say that I wouldn't be the
luckiest kid alive if I got to do it
again
there's stuff going on but we'll have to
just wait and see what happens
foreign
[Music]